aber jetzt mal erst zu christine
aschenberg-dugnus für die fdp kollegen
ja wir sind uns hier alle einig dass
carl corona virus stellt weiterhin eine
große gefahr für die gesundheit aller
bürgerinnen und bürger da und es ist
unsere oberste aufgabe das virus zu
bekämpfen
und ja wir als bundestag
fdp-bundestagsfraktion halten
bundeseinheitliche regelungen für
wichtig sonst hätten wir ja auch nicht
schon vor wochen einen stufenplan
vorgelegt der genau das vorsieht und den
haben sie herr brinkhaus mit ihrer
fraktion damals abgelegt auch die aktive
zustimmung des bundestages weil
rechtsverordnung ist selbstverständlich
zu begrüßen denn eine parlamentarische
beteiligung meine damen und herren ist
immer auch eine qualitätskontrolle bei
dieser qualitätskontrolle und das hat
die anhörung gezeigt ist ihr gesetz aber
durch gefallen meine damen und herren
ihr gesetzesentwurf hat erhebliche
handwerkliche mängel denn alle maßnahmen
zur eindämmung des virus müssen auch
geeignet sein und herr brinkhaus
erstaunlicherweise habe ich zur
geeignetheit dieser mittel überhaupt
nichts von ihnen gehört ich wundere mich
darüber auch nicht denn die vorgesehenen
ausgangssperren sind eben keine
geeigneten maßnahmen
es gibt keine wissenschaftlichen in die
evidenz die belegt dass ausgangssperren
die verbreitung des virus verhindern
allein darauf zu hoffen dass es etwas
bringt reicht eben nicht aus um einen so
schwerwiegenden grundrechtseingriff zu
rechtfertigen meine damen und herren wir
benötigen wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
und keine behauptungen das haben
gerichte so entschieden das sagt der
überwiegende teil der
verfassungsrechtler und wir als
bundestagsfraktion sagen dass auch und
meine damen und herren es existieren
jahr wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse die
erosion forscher haben es dargelegt
ausgangssperren bringen zur eindämmung
desinfektions geschehens reihen
gar nichts sie schränken nur in
unzulässiger weise die grundrechte ein
und treiben die menschen weiter in den
privaten bereich und das kann doch
gerade nicht unser interesse sein meine
damen und herren
der fokus muss auf solchen maßnahmen
liegen die tatsächlich zu einer
eindämmung des virus führen das ist
natürlich impfen impfen impfen testen
bessere aufklärung über kontakt
vermeidung und aha regeln im privaten
bereich nächster punkt die sieben tage
incidents es ist als alleiniger maßstab
völlig ungeeignet das
infektionsgeschehen abzubilden
auch in unserem stufenplan den ich schon
erwähnt habe haben wir bereits diese
faktoren vorgeschlagen und genauso jetzt
in unserem änderungsantrag eine
gewichtete sieben tage inzidenz danach
soll mit einbezogen werden der anteil
der positiv befunde an zahl der
geimpften personen belastung der
intensivstation und so weiter und so
weiter
eine anfrage an das bundesministerium
hat bestätigt die anzahl positiver pcr
test ergebnisse allein zeigt nicht die
schwere der pandemie an
warum haben sie das sind dann nicht in
ihr gesetz geschrieben meine damen und
herren nächste änderungsantrag von uns
modellprojekte die bundes notbremse darf
doch nicht dazu führen dass die
wichtigen modellprojekte wie in
thüringen zum beispiel einfach
abgebrochen werden das widerspricht
jeglicher evidenz meine damen und herren
meine damen und herren wir als fdp
bundestagsfraktion haben von anfang an
für konstruktive gespräche bereit
gestanden auch unter zeitdruck sechs
änderungsanträge ein
entschließungsantrag haben wir ihnen
vorgelegt sie haben alle unsere
argumente jetzt einfach beiseite
geschoben es ist grob fahrlässig hier
ein verfassungsrechtlich fragwürdigen
gesetzesänderung auf den weg bringen zu
wollen
ihre gescheiterte oster ruhe hat doch
gezeigt wie viel vertrauen dabei
verloren gehen kann ein solcher
vertrauensverlust darf sich nicht
wiederholen meine damen und herren im
ergebnis wie
wir das gesetz ablehnen und gestatten
sie mir bitte noch den letzten hinweis
sollten sie unsere änderungsanträge
ablehnen und die ausgangssperre kommen
dann werden wir eine
verfassungsbeschwerde in karlsruhe auf
den weg bringen herzlichen dank
[Applaus]